اصيب اسرائيليون اذا بيجو روح خطيره في
اطلاق نار قرب اريحا شرقيه الضفه الغربيه
ونشر الجيش تعزيزات في المنطقه ضمن عمليه
لتعقب المشتبه بقيامهم بعمليه اطلاق النار
وكان وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي قد قال ان
الفتره المقبله قد تشهد اياما صعبه فضه
وعلى تخوم غزه وتاتي هذه التطورات على
العكس من مخرجات اجتماع العقبه التي تضمنت
الدعوه للتهدئه
ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه
مسارات كيف نفهم تضارب المواقف بشان قراءه
نتائج اجتماع العقبه وهل
تاكيد على مواصله الاستيطان وتصاعد التوتر
في الضفه يشيران الى موت التفاهمات قبل
تطبيقها وما هي مالات التصايد في الضفه
وما خيارات السلطه الفلسطينيه ازاء مواصله
الاحتلال والمستوطنين التصعيد ضد
الفلسطينيين وما هي الارتدادات الداخليه
في اسرائيل لنتائج اجتماع العقبه وكيف
ستنعكس التفاهمات الامنيه على الائتلاف
الحكومي ومستقبله
[موسيقى]
بينما تضمنه البيان الذي صدر عن اجتماع
العقبه واخر التطورات التي شهدتها بلده
حواره ومن بعدها منطقه قريبه من اريحا وما
يصدر من مواقف متتاليه من القيادات
الاسرائيليه وتحركات للجيش الاسرائيلي
مسافه هي اقرب الى المفارقه في بيان
الاجتماع تاكيد على الالتزام بالتهدئه
وبتجميد بناء مزيد من المستوطنات بينما
تقول تغريدات نتنياهو انه لا مجال لتجميد
الاستيطان ومعها تعليمات من وزير الدفاع
في حكومه نتنياهو تفرض نشر مزيدا من
القوات العسكريه والوحدات الامنيه في
مناطق من الضفه الغربيه محدرا من افق
الامين متبلد في الضفه وعلى تخوم غزه
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي شدد على مواصله
عمليه البحث لالقاء القبض على مرافدي
العمليه احياء كانوا او اموات حسب قوله
احاطه امنيه مع قاده المنطقه في الجيش
نتوقع اياما معقده وربما صعبه قد تكون هنا
في يهودا والسامره او في القدس او في
منطقه غزه او عزت بشكل واضح للجيش ولشابك
ولقوات حرس الحدود بالاستعداد التام
لمواجهه كل التهديدات سواء من خلال زياده
العمليات في الميدان وتعزيز القوات لحمايه
المستوطنات ومحاور الطرق والاهم القاء
القبض على المخربين وجلبهم للمحاكمه اما
في المحكمه او في القبر وفقا للتطورات في
الميدان وفي الوقت نفسه ادعو الجميع الى
التهدئه
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من الامم
المتحده الدكتور عبد الحميد صيام الخبير
في شؤون الامم المتحده ينضم الينا من رام
الله الدكتوره عماد ابو عواد مدير مركز
القدس لدراسه الاسرائيليه ومن رام الله
ايضا ينضم الينا الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي
امين وعامل مبادره الوطنيه
الفلسطينيه اهلا بكم جميعا
ابدا معك في رام الله دكتور عماد ابو عواد
وهذا التصعيد كيف تقرا انت هذا التصعيد
وما الذي يرسله من رسائل
تحياتي لك كذلك للضيوف الكرام اولا حاله
الضفه الغربيه الحقيقه منذ العام 2014 حتى
يومنا هذا تشهد تصعيد مستمر هبات مستمره
تنقطع احيانا ثم تعود مره اخرى سلسله من
العمليات الفرديه او حتى التنظيميه التي
تحدث ما بين الفين والاخرى هذا التصعيد
باتسما يميز الضفه الغربيه لسبب بسيط ان
هناك حاله من التمدد الاستيطاني باتت
طبيعيه من قبل الاحتلال هناك ضغط ما بين
الفينه والاخرى لكن الذي يحدث في الاونه
الاخيره ياتي في سياق مهم الا وهو محاوله
اسرائيل ان تحسم الصراع ضد الفلسطينيين
هذا الموضوع بداوا نفتالي بنت ويائير لبيد
العام الماضي مستمر حتى يومنا هذا في ظل
سعي الحكومه الاسرائيليه الى القضاء على
المقاومه الفلسطينيه القضاء على وجود حتى
الشعب الفلسطيني ضمن سياق نفي الوجود وفق
المعتقد الديني الصهيوني من جانب وكذلك
محاوله الصهيونيه الدينيه ان تصل الى
الحلم الكبير بالوصول الى اثنين مليون
مستوطن في الضفه الغربيه وتقسيم المسجد
الاقصى زمانيا ومكانيا في ظل حاله من
الضعف الحكومه الاسرائيلي هذا بطبيعه
الحال يؤدي الى زياده مساحه التصعيد بمعنى
التصعيد الموجود بات يتفاقم خلال الشهور
الاخيره في ظل هذه السياسات المتعمده على
الجانب الاخر هناك شارع فلسطيني بات يرى
بانه لا افق سياسي لا افق اقتصادي في ظل
غياب قياده فلسطينيه تستطيع ان توحد
الشارع الفلسطيني من جانب وان تقدم رؤيه
فلسطينيه بحدها الادنى سواء للاطراف
الاقليميه او الدوليه هذا الامران باتا
يقودان بشكل واضح الى وجود تصادم والى
وجود تصعيد مستمر لا يمكن حقيقه ضمن هذا
السياق القدره على ضبطه جميل من البدايه
يعني اوجست لنا المشهدين يعني في الجانبين
الجانب الاسرائيلي والجانب الفلسطيني ولكن
دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الغريبه والمفارقه
ان المجتمعين في العقبه كان هدفهم بالعكس
كان هدفهم هو خفض التوتر خفض التصعيد ما
يحدث هو العكس تماما وكان تفاهمات العقبه
ولدت ميته اليس كذلك
طبعا ولدت ميته وانا لا اعتقد ان الجانب
الاسرائيلي كان يريد التهدئه بالعكس
الجانب الاسرائيلي يكذب باستمرار بعد
القرار الفلسطيني الخاطئ بسحب مشروع ادانه
الاستيطان من مجلس الامن وعدوا بوقف
الاجتياحات فقاموا بمجزره في نابلس
وبعد اجتماع العقبه لم يكد يجف الحبر على
الورق حتى قاموا بهذه المجزره الوحشيه
وانا اسميها فعلا مجزره هجوم استيطاني
فاشي عنصري على حواره وعلى باقي المدن
الفلسطينيه بورين وزعتره وغيرها الذي يجري
ان هناك حكومه فاشيه عنصريه متطرفه
القطعان الفاشيين الذين هاجموا حوار امس
ذكرونا بالعصابات الصهيونيه التي شنت
المجازر ضد الشعب الفلسطيني عام 48
وبالتالي طبعا الذي يجري ليس تهدئه على
الاطلاق الذي يجري تصعيد اسرائيلي بكل
معنى الكلمه ولكن بالمقابل هناك مقاومه
الدنيا باسله واصرار من الشعب الفلسطيني
ان احدا لن يستطيع ان يكسر ارادتنا او
يكسر مقاومتنا هذا هو الوضع بالضبط ولكن
اذا نظرنا للصوره العامه للوضع الفلسطيني
انا برايي فلسطين تعيش حاله انتفاضه على
شكل موجات متتاليه منذ عام 2015 عندما تم
ادراك فشل المشاريع الاسرائيليه مشاريع
السياسيه ومشروع التسويه وادراك ان الحركه
الصهيونيه لا تريد حلا وسطا مع
الفلسطينيين ربما التغير اليوم ان الموجات
تحولت الى موجه عارمه متواصله وهذا نتيجه
الفاشيه الاسرائيليه وصعود هؤلاء الفاشين
للحكم هذا ما نشهده
لاتفاق الاجتماع الذي جرى في العقبه جرى
ضد الراي غالبيه القوى الفلسطينيه التي
تدرك حقيقه السياسه الاسرائيليه وانتم
سمعتم نتنياهو قال الاستيطان مستمر مش بس
الاستيطان سيستمر التخطيط له سيستمر سموت
ريج قال لن نتوقف ليوم واحد وبنقذير قال
ما جرى في العقبه يبقى في العقبه اذا ماذا
نريد اكثر من ادله على ان هذه الحركه
الصهيونيه وهؤلاء الفاشين في الحكم كل ما
يريدوا تصعيد لان هدفهم ضم الضفه الغربيه
ويحاولون ان استطاعوا ترحيل الفلسطينيين
طيب الدكتور الصيام لو وسعنا الزاويه اكثر
من منظور دولي كيف يقرا هذا التصعيد
يعني في الاول اشكرك على الاستضافه خديجه
وتحيه لضيفيك الكريمين وتحيه للشعب
الفلسطيني العظيم الذي رغم كل
السلبيات التي يعيشها يقاوم هذا الكيان
السرطاني الذي يريد ان يقضي على الشعب
الفلسطيني ويتمدد للقضاء على الدول
العربيه الاخرى وخاصه الدول المجاوره
الوضع هنا في الامم المتحده للاسف وضع
مختل تماما ليس لصالح الفلسطينيين على
الاطلاق يعني هناك الان دعوه لعقد جلسه
مفتوحه لمجلس الامن غدا قدمتها الامارات
ننتظر الاجابه من رئاسه المجلس التي
تحتلها الان مالطا
لجدوله الاجتماع غدا او ربما بعد غد لا
اعرف لغايه الان ولكن الصوره الكليه هنا
يعني مختله لصالح الكيان الصهيوني وروايته
قبل قليل اصدر الامين العام بيانا وممثله
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتره في المحتله
والذي انا اسميه عدو للشعب الفلسطيني اصدر
بيان الامين العام يدين العمليه الارهابيه
في حواره يعني لدانا ذهبت للفلسطينيين كل
ما يقوم به الكيان الصهيوني لا يجرؤون ان
يصدروا بيانا يدين تقوم به اسرائيل ما جرى
في نابلس احد عشر شهيدا لم يصدر بيان
ادانه اما عندما قام الفلسطينيون وقلت
للمتحدث الرسمي قبل قليل هذا الذي قتل هو
جندي في الجيش الاسرائيلي وله مرتبه عاليه
والاخر مستوطن فكيف يمكن للمستوطنين الذين
يسكنون في ارض ليست لهم ياخذونها بالقوه
وهم مدربون ويحملون السلاح وينشرون الرعب
ويقطعون الاشجار
ويحرقون السيارات والبيوت ثم عندما من
غضبه الفلسطيني يقوم يقاوم هؤلاء
المستوطنين اذا هو ارهابي فاي اين الحق في
ذلك هذه هي الحقيقه يجب ان نعرف ان الهروب
للمجتمع الدولي وهذه بيانات السلطه دائما
نناشد المجتمع الدولي اي مجتمع دولي اذا
لم يقم الفلسطينيون ويحمون انفسهم بانفسهم
لا نتوقع شيئا من المجتمع الدولي هذا
مجتمع منافق
يتحرك فورا الى اوكرانيا لكن يرى
للفلسطينيين ويضع اللوم على الفلسطيني
المحتل الذي يواقع تحت الاحتلال مطلوب منه
ان يحمي امن المحتل هذا لم يحدث في
التاريخ وهذا بسبب اوسلو والذي يدخل عامه
الثلاثين على هذه القياده التي وقعت اوسلو
ان تعيد النظر ماذا قدمت للشعب الفلسطيني
خلال ثلاثين عاما هل بقي ارض تقام عليه
دوله فلسطينيه مستقله ذات سياده ومتواصله
هل بقي هناك شيء انظروا ماذا يحدث في
القدس انظروا ماذا يحدث
للالاف من ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني الذي
يطبعون في الاسرى عليهم ان يعتذروا للشعب
الفلسطيني ويلغوا اوسلو حقيقه اذا ارادوا
ان يبقوا جزءا من هذا الشعب
الدكتور نادى ابو عواد مختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي ونريد ان نفهم العقل الامني
الاسرائيلي كيف يفكر في مثل هذه
الظروف عاده كانت دائما المؤسسه الامنيه
الاسرائيليه لديها لديها بعض المحددات في
هكذا اوضاع عدم الذهاب الى اقصى يعني حدود
الاستفزاز لانه الاستفزاز يؤدي ايضا الى
رد فعل فلسطيني هل هذه المره هذه النظريه
صحيحه هناك
حرص على عدم الذهاب الى استفزاز
الفلسطينيين الى ما يمكن يعني يعني الى
يؤدي الى ربما الى تصعيد لا تحمد عقبه
في الاونه الاخيره خديجه هناك شعور لدى
المؤسسات الاسرائيليه بان الدوله تصرك بما
في ذلك المؤسسه الامنيه الاسرائيليه والتي
لديها الشعور بانه نتائج الانتخابات افرزت
حاله من الوجود القيادي المتمثل
بالصهيونيه الدينيه والحريدين والذين لم
يكونوا اساسا جزء من تاسيس الدوله العبريه
بالتالي المؤسسه الامنيه ورئيس الشباب في
اكثر من مره ارسل لبنك فير تحذيرات واضحه
بانه عليك ضبط تصريحاتك عليك ضبط الكثير
من الامور من اجل ان لا يؤدي ذلك الى حاله
من اشتعال الاوضاع في الضفه الغربيه
محاذير المؤسسه الامنيه تصطدم بالواقع
الموجود في الضفه الغربيه بانه سلوك
المستوطنين المسلحين غالبا كونهم جزء من
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يؤدي الى احداث
الكثير من الاستفزاز في المناطق
الفلسطينيه الامر الذي يؤدي الى المزيد من
سلسله العمليات الفلسطينيه وبالتالي
المؤسسه الامنيه اليوم تشعر بالعجز مقابل
شريحه كبيره من هؤلاء المستوطنين جزء من
هؤلاء ما يسمى تدفيع الثمن وجزء اخر الذين
يعيشون في مستوطنه على سبيل المثال قرب
نابلس لا يتوانون عن القاء الحجاره في
احيان كثيره على جيش الاحتلال تحت عنوان
ان هذا الجيش يساهم بشكل او باخر الى ضبط
الامن باتجاه ابقاء الاوضاع ضمن السياق
الصهيوني التقليدي وهذا ما تحدث عنه
بالامس عندما اشار بان المؤسسه الامنيه
محرومه من العمل وبان المستوطنين باتوا
يقودون اسرائيل الى اتجاهات لم تكن موجوده
سابقا بالتالي النظره الامنيه لا زالت
موجوده على حالها لكنها من جانب لا تستطيع
مستوطنين وجزء من هؤلاء كلما زادت تصعيد
الاسرائيلي كلما زاد الوضع اشتعالا وزادت
اعمال المقاومه ولكن هذا هل يخدم نتنياهو
هل يخدم نتنياهو هل يضاعفه هل بالعكس يله
ي الراي العام الاسرائيلي والشارع الذي
ينزل شارع الاسرائيلي الذي ينتفض ضد
نتنياهو ضد الحكومه
الشارع الاسرائيلي اليوم عندما نتحدث عنه
نحن نتحدث حقيقه عن مستويان دولتان دوله
في الداخل خاصه دوله سكان بوجدان وتلافيف
ودوله المستوطنين هناك شعور في الداخل
الاسرائيلي بانه اليوم القضايا الاولى له
هي محاوله منع هذه الحكومه من اجراء
التعديلات القضائيه او كما يسمونه
الانقلاب القضائي من اجل ابقاء المعالم
الصهيونيه الليبراليه التقليديه التي
اقيمت عليها هذه الدوله موجوده وقويه كما
هي هذا الصراع الداخلي حقيقه غيب المشهد
الفلسطيني بشكل او باخر عن الغالبيه
العظمى من المستوطنين في الداخل الامر
الذي انعكس على طبيعه الحراك نتنياهو
يعاني من الكثير من الازمات ليس هذه
الازمه فحسب هناك ازمات اخرى مرتبطه
بالحريديهم الذين كانوا يهددون اليوم
باخراج كتاب ضد بنيامين نتنياهو حول
الميزانيات يعاني من ايثار وبالتالي
[موسيقى]
وهنا ادعو الى تفعيل عمل لجاني الحمايه
الشعبيه في كل مكان وعلى ضوء الجرائم
البشعه التي ارتكبها المستعمرون الفاشيون
وبتوجيه من وزراء في الحكومه الاسرائيليه
فاننا نحمل الحكومه الاسرائيليه كامل
المسؤوليه عن جرائم المستوطنين في حواره
وبقيه الكره المحيطه وسوف يضاف هذا
الاجرام الى ملف محاكمه اسرائيل في
المحاكم الدوليه
دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي نحن في الطريق الى
انتفاضه الثالثه ام نحن فيها ربما في
الطريق الى انفجار للوضع بشكل لا يمكن
التحكم في مستقبلا
نحن في حاله انتفاضه كما ذكرت سابقا ولكن
قد نكون الان متجهين الى انفجار شامل
ودعيني اقول عندما يجري الحديث عن اللجان
الحمايه الشعبيه هذا امر ممتاز ولكن لماذا
لا تعلن السلطه الفلسطينيه بعد كل ما جرى
التخلي المطلق ليس فقط عن التنسيق الامني
بل كل عن كل عقيده التنسيق الامني مع
اسرائيل العقيده التي تريد ان تجبر شعب
تحت الاحتلال ان يقدم الحمايه لمن يحتلونه
وهو عاجز عن حمايه نفسه منهم ومن
المستوطنين
الضغوط التي تمارس عليها يعني ما معنى
العوده الى العقبه والعوده الى الاتفاقيات
التي قررت منظمه التحرير ان تنهيها مجلس
المركزي قرر التحلل من الاتفاقيات واعلنوا
في العقبه العوده للتمسك بها هذا نهج خطا
نهج فشل على مدار 32 عاما وللاسف يعودون
له ولكن دعيني اقول ان الوضع العام الان
اسرائيل التي نشات بالمجازر عام 48 والتي
نشات على سرقه الفلسطينيين سرقه اراضيهم
وسرقه لغتهم وسرقه ارضهم اسرائيل اليوم
التي تكونت
بنيان عنصري وصلت الان الى درجه من التطور
ان كان صحيحا استعمال كلمه تطور تحولت الى
منظومه فاشيه فاشيه بالمعنى الحرفي للكلمه
وهذه هي الخطوره في كل ما يجري الذي جرى
في اسرائيل انقلاب فاشي لانه نتاج طبيعي
لهذا التطور العنصري الذي يقول ان فلسطين
كلها هي لليهود فقط
الجنايات لن تفعل شيئا لان المدعي العام
في محكمه الجنايات الدوليه الان محكوم
باسرائيل وبالولايات المتحده
وبضغوطهم ونحن قلنا اكثر من مره ان هذا
اللي اصبح مدعي عام وهو بريطانيا الجنسيه
يتجنب الموضوع الفلسطيني بالكامل ولن يفتح
الملف بدون ضغوط مباشر عليه وضغوط قويه
لذلك الاتكال على محكمه الجنايات الدوليه
في هذا الظرف بدون ضغط عليها لن يؤثر لن
يؤثر دكتور صيام تشارك دكتور البرغوثي
رايه في انه اللجوء الى محكمه محاكمه
اسرائيل في المحاكم الدوليه لا يعزز موقف
السلطه ولا فائده منه
هذه تصريحات للاستهلاك الداخلي فقط لان
السلطه نفسها تراجعت كثيرا عن
اتفاقيات وعن قرارات تحت الضغط اريد ان
اذكر بعضها تراجعت عن ارسال وفد للتحقيق
في مخيم جنين عام 2002 وكان الوفد موجودا
في جنيه وتحت الضغط الغي الوفد ولم يذهب
الى مخيم جنين تراجعت عن تقرير غولدستون
والذي كان سيصوت عليه في مجلس حقوق
الانسان وتراجعت اخيرا وتراجعت عن تقرير
ديزمون توتو عن معركه بيت حانون عام 2007
وتراجعت الان عن قرار يدين الاستيطان
ويطالب بوقفه
وقبلت بدلا منه بيان رئاسي يدين
الفلسطينيين لانه استخدم كلمه ادانه
لموضوع الارهاب في جمله واحده اربع مرات
وطالب من السلطه ان تتخلى عن الارهاب وان
تقاومه اي هذا هو البيان الذي يخول السلطه
بمقاومه الارهاب اي توجيه سلاحها لشعبها
لذلك اذا كنا نعول ان المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه كما قال اخي مصطفى اولا كريم خان
حتى طريقه انتخابه للمحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه طريقه مشبوهه وكتبت عن ذلك
بالتفصيل في مقالاته
والمحكمه الجنائيه الدوله حبالها طويله
يعني حتى فاتوا بنسوده اللي هي كانت اكثر
اتزانا من كريم خان لم
تقدم الموضوع الا في الشهور الاخيره من
ولايتها اما عندما جاء كريم خان فقال هذا
هو ملف من الملفات موجود في المحكمه
الجنائيه وعندما يصل اليه الوقت نتحدث في
الموضوع بينما ارسل 42 محققا الى اوكرانيا
وزاره اوكرانيا مرت مرتين هو نفسه كريم
خان لذلك من يعول على الاليات الدوليه
لمحاكمه اسرائيل وجرجرتهم الى المحاكم فهو
خادع نفسه هذه تصريحات لامتصاص النقد
الداخليه عليهم ان يسمعوا ما يقوله شعبهم
عليهم ان يقراوا البيانات التي صدرت حول
المشاركه في
اجتماع العقبه عليهم ان يعرفوا نبض الشارع
الفلسطيني الان كله يريد الانفجار لم يعد
يحتمل مثل هذا الاضطهاد هذا الظلم هذا
الذل هذه الاجتياحات عنف المستوطنين قال
كل الناس كل الاتفاقيات السابقه والعوده
الى نقطه الصفر طيب هذا بالنسبه لي وهنا
اعود الى الدكتور عماد هل هناك خوف
اسرائيلي من ان تفعل السلطه ذلك ان يعود
الفلسطينيون الى نقطه الصفر المقاومه
والمقاومه فقط
والغاء كل الاتفاقيات الموقعه عليها سابقا
هناك
الحقيقه ان هناك قناعه اسرائيليه بان
السلطه الفلسطينيه لا تستطيع ان تفعل شيء
وبان السلطه الفلسطينيه لم يعد لها مشروع
الا مشروع محاوله ابقاء السلطه ضمن سياقها
الحالي والحفاظ عليها كمشروع بحد ذاته
وليس كوسيله الى الوصول الى التحرر الوطني
او الوصول الى الدوله السياسيه لكن
اسرائيل على قناعه بان الاحداث المتفاعله
على الارض الان في الضفه الغربيه بما في
ذلك القدس باتت تقود بشكل حقيقي الى
انسلاخ شريحه كبيره من الفلسطينيين باتجاه
الايمان فقط لمشروع المقاومه والتصدي
للاحتلال لذلك الجيل الفلسطيني الجديد
والذي في غالبيته هو من ينفذ العمليات
سواء الفرديه او من خلال تنظيمات في
النهايه متاثره بحاله فكريه مقاومه واسعه
في الضفه الغربيه هذه من شانها مع مرور
الوقت ان تؤدي الى ذوبان كل المشاريع
المناهضه لمشروع المقاومه والمناهضه كذلك
لهذا التوجه وباختصار القول بان الحاله
الفلسطينيه المتفاعله الان على الارض
ستقود الى اخراج حاله قياديه تستطيع ان
تقود الشعب الفلسطيني الى تحقيق اماله
وتحقيق طموحاته التي يصبو اليها بغض النظر
هل رغبت السلطه الفلسطينيه ام هل استخدمت
اسرائيل كل الوسائل المتاحه لديها من اجل
ايقاف ذلك اسرائيل كانت تتحدث منذ سنوات
طويله على انها وصلت الى مرحله على القضاء
دكتور يعني اسرائيل لدينا الادوات لايقاف
ذلك وهي تنتقم من كل بيت ومن كل بلده ومن
كل مدينه ومن كل مكان يخرج منه مقاوم
فلسطيني
اسرائيل تستخدم نعم العقاب الجماعي
اسرائيل تتواجد على الارض بشكل مستمر لكن
كلما زاد تواجدها كلما زادت حده العمليات
الفلسطينيه وزاد عدد العمليات الفلسطينيه
وزاد انتشار الفكر المقاومه الفلسطيني
الشباك الاسرائيلي يتحدث بانه معضلته
الحقيقيه اليوم بانه الجيل الفلسطيني ككل
من المتوقع ان ينفذ عمليه وبالتالي لا
يمكن لاسرائيل ملاحقه كل شاب فلسطيني ولا
يمكن لها ان يعني تقوم بقبر فكره المقاومه
الفلسطينيه على العكس تماما اذا ما اخذنا
الامور وقارناها نجد بانه الحاله
الفلسطينيه رغم الالم رغم الحاله الصعبه
التي يحياها الشارع الفلسطيني حاليا لكنه
من ناحيه المقاومه سواء في العمل على
الارض وامتلاكه مقاومه حقيقيه وقويه في
قطاع غزه وايمان والفكر بحاله المواجهه
وضروره المواجهه يمكن القول بانه في افضل
احواله من هذه الناحيه رغم التضحيات
الكبيره والالم الكبير لكن في النهايه
التضحيات هي جزء من مشروع التحرر لاي شعب
يخضع لي الاحتلال وهذا بالمناسبه تعي
اسرائيل
المستشار السابق في الامن القومي الامريكي
اهلا بك سيدي
هذه الخلطه التصعيد الحاليه مفتاح وقفها
وحلها ونجم اسرائيل في يدي واشنطن ما الذي
يمكن ان تفعله واشنطن
شكرا على الاستضافه
بالنسبه الى اداره الرئيس الامريكي بايدن
فهي وللاسف
يبدو ان الوقت يلعب ضدها فهذا التصعيدات
الاخيره التي حصلت في الاشهر الاخيره في
الضفه الغربيه
قد
تعززت
وازدادت بسبب هذا النوع من الاحداث
لا يمكن برايي ان نرسم بانها منفصله وغير
مترابطه لان هناك
جهود منسقه من اجل زياده التصعيد وزياده
التوتر بين الطرفين
فان كلا من وزير الخارجيه
بايدن وغيرهما
بحاجه الى بذل جهود حديثه ووضع الكثير
ضغوطات على الجانبين السلطه الفلسطينيه
وكذلك حكومه نتانياهو من اجل
الامتناع عن استفزاز الطرف الاخر وهذا
اعتقد ان اداره الرئيس بايدن تحاول ان
تقوم به
وذلك من حيث السرديه من حيث كافه
التصريحات فهي تحاول ان تسيطر على هذه
النار التي لا يجب ان تخرج عن السيطره
ولكنها تقدم نفسها كضامن وهي بالفعل يعني
حتى في قمه او في لقاء العقبه كانت
الولايات المتحده هي الضامن لي هذه
التفاهمات التي خرج بها هذا اللقاء كدوله
ضامنه لتطبيق هذه التفاهمات ماذا يمكن ان
تفعل اذا
اداره بعيدا
بحاجه الى
او هي في وضع فريده من نوعه لاننا جزء او
طرف خارجي وهذا يطرح دائما امامنا الكثير
من التحديات ما يجب ان يحصل فعلا هو
تعزيز هذه الجهود الدبلوماسيه التي يمكن
لوزير الخارجيه
عن يسخرها من اجل الضغط على الطرفين
وشمل وادراج اكبر عدد ممكن من الاشخاص ومن
الاطراف من اجل توصل الى النوع من الحل
شكرا جزيلا لك نكتفي بهذا القدر شكرا
جزيلا لك
المستشار السابق في الامن القومي الامريكي
كنت معنا منه
ونشكر ايضا ضيوفنا في هذه الحلقه الدكتور
عبد الحميد صيام الخبير في شؤون الامم
المتحده كان معنا من الامم المتحده ومن
رام الله الدكتور عماد ابو عواد مدير مركز
القدس للدراسات الاسرائيليه ومن رام الله
ايضا الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي امين عام
المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر لكم منا اطيب المنى والى
اللقاء